[Musique]
bien là écoutez je vous présente la
section handi pétrin de l'as ptt
mulhouse c'est tout nouveau c'est un
démarrage à la rentrée 2010 8
l'objectif de cette section c'est de
sortir des enfants handicapés moteurs de
leurs fauteuils et de vraiment de leur
faire comprendre qu'ils ont la
possibilité de tout seul de faire de la
marche et de la course à pied pour ça
ils vont utiliser un petra c'est cette
espèce de ce tricycle qui est comme une
draisienne où ils ont à la fois une
selle et un plastron à l'avant et qui
leur permet de se propulser avec les
jambes mais aussi avec les bustes et
bien la meilleure démonstration c'est
encore elle qui vont vous la faire aller
les filles c'est parti
[Musique]
allez alors chaque indiqué handicap a sa
spécificité
l'important c'est que il arriva à se
rendre compte qu'ils avancent hull qui
son autonomie est que pour une fois ce
n'est pas le fauteuil qui les dirigent
mais eux mêmes alors le ptra de nombreux
avantages d'abord la joie de pratiquer
le sport ensemble quand on a été sportif
on sait combien c'est important d'être
solidaire à l'entraînement de se
retrouver pour pratiquer la même
activité tous ensemble et puis il ya
aussi le travail thérapeutique c'est à
dire que pour eux c'est hyper important
de développer leurs qualités physiques
de base c'est-à-dire la densité osseuse
le développement pulmonaires et
cardiaques qu'ils ont vraiment pas
l'habitude de faire eux les soins qu'ils
ont c'est de la kiné de l'ergot et à
aucun moment ils ne développent ce qu'on
appelle les qualités de base
le sport c'est la santé
et c'est un petit peu cette idée qu'on
veut faire passer et on essaye
d'intervenir auprès d'enfants parce
qu'on pense aussi que c'est eux qui ont
20 qui vont avoir cette habitude de vie
de faire du sport vous imaginez bien que
le matériel pour handicapés est très
très onéreux et que les enfants ne
peuvent pas s'acheter du matériel
personnel
donc c'est vraiment au club d'avoir de
pouvoir leur proposer du matériel
adopter à leur taille
donc on a fait notre entrée il ya une
semaine nous avons actuellement 4 petra
nous avons quatre à cinq enfants et donc
le conseil départemental va nous aider à
acheter le cinquième petra pour pouvoir
proposer un petra par enfant
[Musique]